okay well we're going to carry on with
our model selection session
we've done best subset selection now
we're going to do forward stepwise
selection so best subset is is quite
aggressive looking at all possible
subsets forward stepwise is a greedy
algorithm at each time it includes the
next best variable but it keeps
it produces a nested sequence so it's a
much less
adventurous search
it keeps a nested sequence of models
each time you just add the variable that
improves the fit the most
so we also back using our um markdown
format in
and and so we'll continue with that so
let's have a look at the screen
and
we've got our heading for step by
selection
and we're back using reg subsets
and it's the same function that did best
subsets but yeah we tell it method
equals forward and we also want the
number of variables to use the full
number of variables which is is 19.
and so that's really fast as well and
there's a summary for that just as there
was for the
best subsets
and now this this one if you look
through the models that were selected
you'll find that they exactly nested
so each new model includes all the ones
variables that were before plus one new
one
and so if you study that
you'll you'll discover that
and we can plot the cp statistic
um a bigger pardon we make the plot for
this model this the the schematic plot
plot like we did before
and it looks very similar to what we saw
for big
best subsets
different in some places
but the same kind of structure near the
the good end which is the low cp end
where
there's a consistent group of variables
that are in a little bit of fluctuation
down at this end over here
in terms of which of those variables are
in
okay
so
we've got best subset and forward set
stepwise and we can select the models
using cp there's also adjusted r squared
and bic
but here we're going to actually use a
validation set
so what we're going to do
is we're going to pick
a subset of the observations and put
them aside and use them as a validation
set and the other as a training data set
so let's see how we might do that
and this is a little different to the
way we do it in the book
and so
first of all we see the dimension of
hitters it's there's 263 rows
so we're going to roughly go for
two-thirds training and one-third test
and approximately two-thirds training is
180 observations
and so that's what we'll do
and just for reproducibility we'll set
the random number seed and you can set
it to any number we set it to one
doesn't matter
well it does matter but you know for our
purposes we're not particular
okay so here we go
there's a command here first
first of all inside sequence 263
creates
seq 263 it just creates the numbers one
two three four up to 263 so it's a
shortcut for doing that
okay
and here we're using the sample command
so we're going to sample from that
sequence
we're going to take a sample of size 180
and we're going to say replace equals
false so this will sample 180 indexes of
observations
okay
and let's just look at them well there
they are there's 180 numbers chosen at
random from the sequence 1 to 263.
so those we're going to use that set of
index those rows we're going to use for
our fit in
so regfit.forward now we run rake
subsets again
and everything's the same as before
except now
we tell it to use the dataframe hitters
but indexed by the rows
in train
okay
and so that'll use this subset of of of
data
okay
so
that's fit the model now we're going to
work out the the validation errors on on
the remainder of the data
so we know there's 19 subset models
because they're 19 variables so we'll
set up a vector
having 19 slots
and
we'll make a x matrix corresponding to
our validation data set
so here we use the model matrix because
we want to use the formula that we used
in building the model which was salary
twiddle dot
which means model salary as a function
of all the other variables in in the
hitters data frame but celery is a
response
and so we put that formula we give that
as an argument to model matrix
and we tell it that the data it should
use is hitters
but now rather than indexing by train we
index by minus train which is a really
nice device in r
for excluding
the observations index by train so that
just leaves a remainder
so that's a negative index set
okay
so we build that
that test
model matrix
and now we're going to make our
predictions for each model so we're in a
loop for i equals 1 to 19.
we use the coefficient to to extract the
coefficients
for the model of size id equals i so so
i is going to index the size
and we go in a loop and do it for each
size
and
now
the unfortunate thing is not a predict
method for reg subsets which would have
been handy
so we basically got to do it all our
self
and so the coefficient vector that comes
back if we look at it well we can't yet
because we're in a loop
it's just got the subset of variables
that are used in that model and so to
get the right elements of x
of of x test
we have to index the names of the index
the columns by the the names that are on
the coefficient vector right so that's
one way of doing that
so that's the subset of columns of of x
tests that correspond to the variables
that are in this
current coefficient vector
and then we do a matrix multiply by the
coefficient vector
so it's a little bit
of a loaded line
and
and then having got the prediction so
that gives the predictions
and then
we
compute the mean squared error so
there's the hitters dollar salary minus
train
minus the predictions
square it and take the mean and put that
in validation errors and that's the end
of our loop
okay so that worked pretty quickly and
then we plot we're going to plot the
root mean squared error so we plot that
in a plot and there we have it so that's
a validation error
it's slightly jumpy
which is which is okay i mean this is
these are data there's only you know
there's less than 90 observations in the
validation set so there's going to be a
bit of noise
um but there seems to be a minimum here
around five
the ten that we chose before is a little
bit higher than the minimum
we may as well put the the residual sum
of squares for the the model on the same
plot
so uh notice we we remove the first one
this corresponds to the null model um
which was not included in in our
validation plot here
and so there's a residual sum of squares
and notice of course as as it must do
the residual sum of this is the root
mean
residual sum of squares
it's monotone decreasing as it has to be
because forward step wise each time
includes a variable that improves the
foot the most
and so therefore by definition it's got
to improve the residual sum of squares
on the training data okay
and we may as well annotate our plot
with a legend
it's very easy to do we tell the legend
command to put the legend in the top
right corner we give it the legend
and and and a few more details
um we tell it
that well let's just do it and see it
and you see in the command
how we achieved
how we achieved that i use a
pch plot in character 19 quite often it
gives you a solid dot which is often
nicer to to visualize on the screen
especially if you're doing it in color
and uh
so this was a little tedious we had to
write our own basically method we had to
write code for doing the prediction
um we're going to use predict we will
make predictions from rig subsets model
in the future so
we're going to end the session by
actually just writing a function for
doing that
and
we often do this in in r
you know when we find ourselves
repeating code that's tedious we write a
little function to do it for ourselves
so we write it this is actually right in
a method for predict
for a reg subsets object so predictor
drag subsets
and
we give it
argument object that's going to be the
reg subset object that we want to
predict from we give it new data and id
which is going to be the id of the model
it's slightly technical but
not too hard to understand the rig
subsets object's got a call a component
called a call
and and that's the the
the call that was used to create it
and
part of the call is the formula and so
we can extract that formula through this
little incantation here
and then using the formula we make a a
model matrix from it so much to the way
much like we did before then we extract
the coefficient and do the matrix
multiply
and so we put that all together in a
function which we'll just enter into a
session now and so now that function is
defined and will be ready for us to use
in the next session where we're going to
actually use cross validation